et autour de la table également il y a
Christine palouet et Jean-Marie Guynemer
bonsoir alors vous venez parler vous du
festival électro chic la 7e édition va
bientôt démarrer alors juste pour vous
présenter Jean-Marie guynevert vous êtes
directeur des affaires culturelles de la
ville de Versailles et Christine Pallot
directrice à la culture de
l'agglomération Versailles Grand Parc
alors d'électro on en parle justement
aussi avec cette information juste avant
de parler d'électrochimique la
billetterie de l'événement Versailles
électro est ouvert depuis ce midi ce
sera le samedi 27 mai dans les jardins
du château de Versailles en tête
d'affiche on peut voir juste l'animation
s'afficher de la du côté de la régie et
il y aura Martin Solveig et kungs alors
on me dit qu'on ne l'a pas en régie
juste pour vous préciser que le prix des
places va de 45 à 250 euros et que les
informations et la réservation est à
faire du côté du site du château de
Versailles spectacle alors on parle d'un
autre événement là on parlait de
Versailles électron on parle bien
d'électro chic à présent juste avant de
parler du tremplin des voies c'est un
événement qui prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur d’années en année et cette
septième édition va réunir 23 artistes
dans huit communes de Versailles Grand
Parc ce sera sur deux weekends du 9 au
18 mars c'est une septième édition qui
se démarque des autres ou finalement des
dans la continuité de ce qui a pu se
faire dans les éditions précédentes
Christine Paolo on est dans la
continuité de ce qui de ce qu'on
développe au fur et à mesure des années
avec des artistes de renommée
internationales qui viennent d'un peu
partout dans le monde et puis aussi des
jeunes artistes que qu'on tâche de
révéler ou au travers du Tremplin ou
dans la programmation des artistes
différents on découvre aussi peut-être
différentes branches de la musique
électro
d'électrogique depuis le départ c'est
précisément d'être représentatif autant
que faire ce peu de toutes les
esthétiques de l'électro il y a
énormément de choses le point de départ
c'était évidemment la Versailles touch
donc l'électro à la française qui est né
à Versailles ne l'oublions pas et sur le
territoire
c'est totalement faux ce sont les tous
les autres oui mais pas Daft punker par
contre c'est bien vrai c'est également
le cas de bien des autres de Arnaud
robotcigny enfin ils ont tous fait ils
ont tous quasiment mon côtoyés sur les
bancs du mamie c'est Jules Ferry c'est
dire si leur proximité est grandes
mais cette pour le coup pour ce qui est
de Daft Punk c'est non voilà tous les
autres c'est oui et précisément c'est
appuyé sur cette antériorité cette
histoire pour il y a 7 ans de ça
maintenant puisque c'est la c'est la 8
ans de ça même c'est la 7e édition pour
justement régénérer cette acquis cette
histoire bah c'est merveilleuse quand
même qui fait que des des gamins c'était
tous des lycéens de Jules Ferry un
moment donné se sont mis à faire dans
leur cave avec deux trois beatbox mets
de la musique complètement nouvelle qui
nous a tous marqué on a tous donc enfin
tous en tout cas ma génération on a tous
dansé sur sur effectivement sur R et
quelques autres morceaux de légende et
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est précisément de
de renouer avec cette légende mais avec
des jeunes talents d'accord de jeunes
talents des jeunes et moins jeunes mais
surtout de continue à servir de tremplin
sur le territoire à deux jeunes talents
sur une aire géographique de plus en
plus large puisque au début on était
grosso modo sur trois communes et là on
est sur 8 communes donc chaque année il
y en a une de plus quasiment on va
parler de la programmation
électro c'est une musique qui vous plaît
ou enfin vous en écoutez régulièrement
Audrey
du coup j'accompagne de plus en plus
d'artistes qui ont un petit mélange
électro parce que par exemple j'ai une
artiste qui est électro afro donc voilà
avec un DJ avec un guitariste et voilà
donc
dans vos musiques par exemple à vous
sous le 11 pas du tout mais un peu de
tout c'est je m'inspire un peu tout je
chante c'est de m'intéresser un peu à
tous les styles et puis voilà de me
prévenir un peu de chaque influence
mais c'est vrai qu'avec maintenant les
plateformes on a accès vraiment à tout
type de musique et on s'arrête plus du
tout
au style et donc oui moi c'est vrai que
je m'influence je mon influence elle est
vraiment de partout et notamment
d'électro d'ailleurs pour le festival
électro chic est-ce que ça s'adresse à
des passionnés d'électro ou même des non
initiés peuvent venir sur place on est
vraiment ouvert à tous types de public
on a même y compris des master class
pour des gamins qui ont qui ont 6 7 ans
donc on commence très jeune c'est comme
ça que ça commence à c'est comme ça que
ça commence non tout c'est vraiment tout
public alors effectivement la variété de
la programmation fait qu'on peut se
rester à des puits qui sont vraiment des
points tibus et des fans et puis des
gens qui ont honnêtement ils connaissent
rien
voir même son on peut parfois aller de
l'électro sur quasiment l'électro pop on
crée le cas par rapport en 2018 quand on
a fait venir l'impératrice au mont
entier on est sur vraiment une grande
diversité d'esthétique pour précisément
toucher capter le maximum de
de public on va écouter tout de suite un
petit medley des artistes qui seront à
l'affiche de ce festival électrochimique
[Musique]
gâteau bien
un petit échantillon ce qu'on disait à
23 artistes qui sont programmés on
entend bien ce mélange des esthétiques
dans un même festival c'est vraiment le
pari parce qu'effectivement la plupart
des festivals électro choisissent une
ligne très très caractéristique le pari
qui a été fait depuis le départ ils
étaient particulièrement le l'objet de
nos discussions nos premières
discussions avec Joël gainsburger qui
est le patron de Londres et avec lequel
on a créé ce festival il y a maintenant
8 ans c'était précisément d'arriver à
avoir cette diversité des esthétique qui
était aussi revend la diversité des
villes participantes et chaque villa
s'aligne quelque part et Christine
Pallot c'est aussi important Jean-Marie
Guilbert le disait tout à l'heure de
mettre en avant si la jeunesse les
jeunes talents puisque on va parler de
quelques têtes d'affiches mais il y a
quand même des jeunes artistes c'est eux
qui sont mis en avant aussi au travers
ce festival on a des jeunes artistes qui
viennent des tremplins des années
précédentes et certains qui viennent et
reviennent qui ont grandi et qu'on
continue à valoriser accompagner et puis
effectivement on a d'autres d'autres
têtes d'affiches peut-être parmi ces
jeunes aussi montrer là on a vu des
images enfin et écouter Olympe 4000 on a
une place des compositrices et des DJ
femmes très importants dans la
programmation de cette année on l'a pas
forcément fait exprès c'est la réalité
de la création artistique d'aujourd'hui
et puis on est vraiment ravis
d'accueillir Irène Brezel qui a été
récompensé vendredi soir pour la
meilleure musique de film par par les
César donc voilà c'est c'est super pour
cette valorisation de ces artistes là je
ne sais moins jeunes artiste femme aussi
qui sont de plus en plus de place se
passe dans cette scène électro des noms
alors mb14 peut-être qui parle un peu
plus au grand monde je vois ceux qui
acquiesce principalement connu sur le
beatbox aussi hein exactement c'était
c'était aussi l'un des paris c'est de
s'ouvrir à ce type d'esthétique là on
est vraiment dans l'électro pour autant
mais c'est vrai que c'est la première
fois qu'on a ce type d'artiste dans la
programmation on espère qu'ils vont
cartonner on est on est précisément au
Palais des Congrès parce qu'on fait le
pari du carton donc on est dans une
grande salle c'est aussi l'une des
premières fois que le c'est la première
fois que le Palais des Congrès de
Versailles participent en tant que
programmateur et sale au festival
électrochimique donc c'est pour nous
doublement une première et là on reste
complètement dans la ligne de
l'esthétique et de la de la
programmation d'électrochique ils seront
également suivis d'un groupe qui lui est
directement issu d'être en plein qui est
i am Sparrow qui sera programmé pour la
deuxième fois du coup parce que il y a
aussi une logique de suite par rapport à
tes talents là c'est qu'on peut les
retrouver deux ans trois ans plus tard
d'accord et les voir grandit les
entendre grandir au sein
d'électrochimique exactement alors il y
a aussi alors on revient à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure le mélange des
styles aussi on peut mélanger l'électro
hip-hop notamment la fine équipe qui
vont être présents à Chaville le le 10
mars juste sur les infos pratiques
est-ce que le billet forcément les
billets sont à apprendre à l'avance
Christine Paolo il vaut mieux parce que
il y a certaines salles qui commencent à
se remplir très très vite mais bon enfin
voilà il y a vraiment des formats très
différents des tarifs très variables
aussi en tout cas le moyen de passer une
excellente soirée
à tous les coups la fourchettes de prix
à peu près pour avoir une place et 25
euros franchement c'est c'est vraiment
très accessible et toute la
programmation sur festival
électrochimique.fr avec le site bien sûr
qu'il s'affiche en bas de l'écran donc
je rappelle les dates du 9 au 18 mars 8
communes de Versailles Grand Parc on a
compris que c'est un festival qui a
s'étendait à de plus en plus de communes
de l'agglomération info et raisins sur
le lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
la dernière question que j'ai envie de
vous poser petit tour de table je vais
vous donner le chèque à la parole les
ingrédients d'une édition une septième
édition réussie Christine palot la
complicité entre les partenaires
Jean-Marie Guilbert la diversité des
talents qui s'exprime voilà donc tout
est tout est dit avant le début de ce
festival